Mình sẽ tự, và ký stand phong toàn tù đối xa là mặt đẹp trình bị cho vòng đàn phản đầu tiên giới Mỹ về Iran,
sau bối cảnh cả cuộc không kích quý sweren bó libang tế tục đezuá là mục đồ thật bánh.
Giờ trước, và ký stand đã thích là cuộc an ninh quen khai sản xe rena,
nơi dự kiến đón phá đoàn hai nước, đúng thời yêu cầu khác dời đi để phục vụ sự kết.
Tuy nhiên, trên bóng lối thoại bị phụ bão khi Iran tình bú sẽ không đặt thật nếu Israel tế tục không kích nhiều cuộc tài libang,
sau lực tình công lượng trước đó khiến hợp hai chân lắm mình với thế mà.
Fé Israel và Mỹ thì khẳng định libang không thuộc phản vi lần bánh trong khi Iran bạc ký stand cho rằng thỏ thất,
cần phải bao gồm gặp của cuộc này.
Hẹp Iran đã tài phong qua, ở biệt hả một dù lận bánh hai tận về Mỹ,
các khí lực khiến lưu lộ bản tài giám mạnh và về giòn đoạn,
nhìn trọng một cung nội lực tàn cầu.
Giờ giờ, vô giòn ngày tăng bọc, có thể điểm gần một chăm năm mấy đô lầm ý của thông,
phản lạnh lông ngày tị trường trước Mỹ có xung đột lâu thông.
Các bên dự kiện sẽ thảo lợp mở giống như bằng sang libang và yên man,
sống bất đồng số sắc cùng dịch biệt quan sự thực biệt,
khiến khả năng đà được đủ phá vẫn còn bằng gồm.